- Well, your son's name is Daniel.
So did you name him after
your "Karate Kid" character?
Please say yes.
- I don't know why you
draw that conclusion.
(laughter)
I mean, I never thought
of that till this...
Well, you know what?
(Kelly laughs)
Oh, here we are out in the
east end of Long Island.
Yep, these shots are unbelievable.
You can't... Everything is out there.
(laughing)
My wife's best friend growing
up was her cousin Daniel.
So she always had an
affinity for that name,
and it was a classic Biblical
name that I always loved.
I mean the "Karate Kid's"
character initially in the script
was Danny Weber, and when they cast me,
they added more vowels
to make him Italian.
I don't know where that
came from, and on top of it,
the Daniel was something
I was steadfast on.
So I always loved the name,
and it meant something to her.
It was like is it too
soon? Should we name?
Will he have to care? Would this be good?
And we went for it, and I still
think it's a beautiful name.
He's proud of it.
Maybe a couple of years, he was
like, "Dad, did you have to?
Did you really?" (laughter)
But now he's Dan, and he's his own.
It's wonderful, it's wonderful.
- I think it's really
cool. I think it's sweet.
Did you get to keep anything
from the original movie?
I saw you took the
guitar from "Crossroads".
Did you take anything?
- Yeah, I take stuff, I take stuff.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I like it.
- I took the can of tuna
from "My Cousin Vinny."
That's... I won't open it.
- I love "My Cousin Vinny"! Oh my God!
- "The Karate Kid", I had
more than a few things.
I got the '47 Ford convertible,
which I did not bring with me.
- [Kelly] Wow!
- That's on the set of "Cobra Kai",
that photograph you're
looking at right now.
And so, that is the original
car from the original film.
And one of the things
that I did bring with me
is what is called a
hachimaki, which is basically
most people would say, "Oh, the headband."
But this is the original.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- The one I wore in the film.
I mean, I wore a few of
them, but I kept this one.
And there you go.
What's interesting about it
is it wasn't necessarily an
early part of the script.
It was in a rehearsal with Pat Morita
that he had this sort of
handkerchief he would use,
and this was it.
And you know, he would
say, "This is a hachimaki."
And he spoke of the
Japanese-American culture
and in this case, Okinawan culture,
and what it meant when a
teacher gifts one to his student
and the, you know, the weight
and respect that is given
and when one is handed to the next.
And I love all those types of traditions.
So we try to carry that forward
in the "Cobra Kai" series as well.
It's important to have those
Miyagi-isms ringing true
throughout the series, you know?
- Yeah. I loved it.
I don't even remember what it's called,
but I remember I had one of the things
that was like doo-doo-doo-doo,
and the little things would-
- Oh, the drum.
- The drum, yeah.
I would be in my room,
and I'd be like, "This is
my moment. I'm about to..."
I mean, I was so weird,
and I loved that thing.
(laughter)